-In yet another
stunning development,
the committee investigating
the coup attempt
on January 6th
deposed Ginni Thomas,
the spouse of a sitting
Supreme Court justice,
as more video evidence emerged
of another Trump ally,
Roger Stone, discussing plans
before the election
to declare victory
and overturn the results
if Trump lost.
For more on this,
it's time for A Closer Look.
♪♪
There was a huge development in
the congressional investigation
of the January 6th
insurrection today,
when the committee
investigating the attack
took the unprecedented step
of deposing the spouse
of a sitting
Supreme Court justice.
-Happening today here
in Washington, Ginni Thomas,
the wife of the Supreme Court
justice Clarence Thomas,
is meeting with
the January 6th Committee.
-We know that members want to
talk to her about text messages
she exchanged
with Mark Meadows,
the former White House
Chief of Staff,
about efforts
to overturn the election.
-She also texted with
Trump's then Chief of Staff,
Mark Meadows,
after the election,
pressing him not to concede
to Joe Biden.
-That's right --
Ginni Thomas,
the wife
of Justice Clarence Thomas,
was texting Donald Trump's
Chief of Staff,
urging him not to concede.
I feel like that's not
what the framers had in mind
when they imagined separate but
equal branches of government.
I'm just guessing here,
but I'm going to assume
Martha Washington wasn't writing
secret letters by candle light
to the first Chief Justice,
John Jay -- history fact.
I'm guessing she wasn't
writing him letters on parchment
that said,
"John Adams is a moron.
Don't let him win
the election of 1796
or they'll make a miniseries
about him one day
starring Paul Giamatti.
Yeah, the guy from 'Billions'!"
I'm no legal expert,
but I feel like
if you're the spouse
of a sitting
Supreme Court justice,
you shouldn't be texting
anyone in the government
about anything,
let alone a coup.
That'd be like if I found out
my wife was texting James Corden
about how great
his monologue was last night.
And then I'd confront her
and I'd say,
"But he's on
at the same time as me."
And she'd say,
"Wait, you're on at 12:30?"
And then I'd say,
"Actually, it's 12:37,
and please don't ask me why,
because the network won't
explain it to me either."
And by the way,
those clips are underselling
what Ginni was actually doing.
She wasn't just texting
Trump's Chief of Staff
and urging Trump not to concede.
She had direct communications
with state lawmakers
in Arizona and Wisconsin,
pressuring them --
again, as the spouse
of a sitting
Supreme Court justice --
to overturn Biden's victory.
And she was also texting
some truly bat[bleep]
conspiracy theories
from the craziest corners
of the Internet --
stuff I had honestly
never even heard about
until the Ginni Thomas story
broke.
-The Washington Post obtained
copies of messages
that had been turned over
to the January 6th committee
revealing that Ginni Thomas sent
former Trump Chief of Staff
Mark Meadows
a barrage of texts
in the weeks after
the 2020 election,
urging him to try
to overturn the results.
She referred to wild
far-right conspiracy theories,
sending Meadows a link
to an absolutely,
just insane YouTube video
that's since been taken down
which was centered around
a fake QAnon conspiracy theory.
After she texted
that video to Meadows,
Thomas added,
"I hope this is true."
-Right after the election,
she quoted to Meadows
the language then circulating
on pro-Trump sites,
"Biden crime family and
ballot fraud co-conspirators
(elected officials, bureaucrats,
social media censorship mongers,
fake stream media reporters,
etc)
are being arrested and detained
for ballot fraud right now
& over coming days, & will be
living in barges off GITMO
to face military tribunals
for sedition,"
adding, "I hope this is true."
-You know, it almost --
almost -- makes me feel bad
for Clarence Thomas.
I mean, we all know a couple
that has to leave
every party early
because one spouse
decided to pre-game
with back pills and Everclear,
and 20 minutes in,
they're loudly describing
some foot problem they have.
"Yeah, it's turning green.
It's about to fall off.
Now, who wants to dance?"
But think about
how insane that is.
Ginni Thomas didn't just think
the election was stolen.
She thought Joe Biden
and the "Biden crime family"
would be arrested
and living on barges off Gitmo.
And here's my question --
Why a barge off Gitmo
instead of just Gitmo itself?
Let's just assume
for the sake of the argument
that all the crazy [bleep]
she was texting
turned out to be true --
that Hugo Chávez teamed up
with the CIA
and Dominion voting machines
to rig the election
using ballots
smuggled in from China
covered in bamboo fibers,
but then Trump caught them
by secretly watermarking
the real ballots
and then conducted
a sting operation
to arrest the Biden crime family
and prove that the election was,
in fact, stolen.
Let's just assume for a moment
that all of that is true,
and, whoa, whoa,
I see why they're into this!
Wh-- It's like being
on Molly and Mountain Dew
at the same time.
Whoa.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, if all of that is true,
why would the military
go to all the extra trouble of
building a barge off Gitmo
when they already have Gitmo?
That's what Gitmo is for.
Is the assumption
that Biden can't swim,
so he'd never escape?
Because he does seem like
one of those old dudes
who would just strip down
and jump in the lake
no matter how cold it was.
"Grandpa, the water's freezing."
"Come on in.
It'll put some hair
on your chest."
Seriously?
Why a barge off the prison?
Have they ever done that with
any other criminal suspect ever?
Alright, we caught
the River City Strangler.
Should we put him
in Alcatraz?
Nah, for a guy that bad, he goes
on the Alcatraz catamaran.
[ Laughter ]
And in case all of this
isn't weird enough for you,
Thomas made her appearance today
even weirder
when she arrived
and a reporter caught up to her
and tried to ask her questions.
-Ms. Thomas, why do you feel
like you need
to speak to the committee
to clear your name?
-Thank you for being here.
-Did you speak with your husband
about your beliefs
of the election being stolen?
-Thank you for your question.
Look forward
to answering the members.
-[ Laughing ] Oh!
What is going on here?
Is this one of those promotions
for that new movie "Smile"?
If you only -- If you had only
been communicating
with Ginni Thomas via text
and this was the first time
you saw her face, you'd think,
"Oh, no.
Oh, that lady was crazy
the whole time.
Oh, no!
I texted her
about government stuff."
So, Thomas' texts were insane.
But in a way,
they weren't shocking
because, as we've said
many times before,
Trump surrounds himself
with a group of people
who are, in addition
to being very dangerous
and deeply corrupt,
also just incredibly weird.
As a New York City
real-estate mogul,
Trump could have had his pick
of sophisticated
white-collar criminals.
Instead, he assembled
a team of mutants
who failed
their X-Men auditions.
"There's Pillow Man.
His pillows may be soft,
but his voice is loud enough
to shatter glass.
There's Former Mayor.
He can pull the skin all the way
back behind his head.
Not sure what good
that's going to do,
but it's cool
to watch him do it.
Then there's Roger,
the time-traveling drug dealer.
You know, he's the one who gave
Sherlock Holmes all that opium."
Now, we'll get to
the newest developments
involving Trump confidant
Roger Stone in a second.
But first, let's start with
My Pillow CEO Mike Lindell,
because, you know, why not?
Lindell had his phone seized
by the FBI
while he was
in a Hardee's drive-through
as part of an investigation
into a voting-machine breach
in Colorado
that he may have
been connected to.
And now he's complaining that
his new phone has nothing on it
because he didn't back up any
of the data on his old phone.
-I don't use a laptop.
I don't use a computer.
Everything was on that phone.
One of the things --
there were files on that phone
that you can't get through
the cloud that were passwords.
Some of them passwords
were so --
I wire money from different
accounts back and forth.
And I have to look those
passwords up in those files.
I can't get to those, Steve.
I can't get anything.
I took the number
and transferred it
from my carrier
to another phone,
but the phone is blank.
It's missing all these things.
We -- This phone --
Like I said, Steve,
I would've rather --
almost rather they arrested me
than took my phone.
-I bet he offered that to
the FBI and they said no.
"Just take me with you!"
"No, we're good."
"Please!
Everything was on that phone,
including my address,
so I don't know how to
get home without it.
Just let me come sleep with you
and sleep in jail behind --
oh, bars."
Also, Mike, every time
you defend yourself,
you seem to describe
a different potential crime
you maybe committed.
Why are you wiring money
back and forth
between different accounts
all the time?
"I'm always moving money around
in an effort
to make it look like
I got enough to cover my debts.
And now I can't --
Things are about to get bad."
For some reason, these doinks
are always on camera
complaining about something
extremely weird, like Rudy,
who recently went on his podcast
to insist once again that
the election was stolen
and also complained that no one
was inviting him on TV anymore.
-They're lying about
January 6th.
They're trying to make alternate
electors look like a crime.
There's nothing wrong with it.
It was absolutely in the open.
There was no fraud
attached to it.
They want us ignored.
They want us put in prison.
They want all our property
taken from us.
They don't want us
to be allowed to be employed.
And they don't want any
television station to put us on.
And they say so.
And the television stations
comply.
That's not fascism?
-No, it's not.
I don't...
I don't think it's fascism
so much as not wanting
to scare the children at home.
I mean, this should come with
a content warning.
This looks like one of
those photos they used for
the Surgeon General's warning
on a pack of cigarettes.
Also, can we go back to this?
-They don't want us to be
allowed to be employed.
-Who's "us"?
They don't want you employed.
And you shouldn't be employed.
You're 78.
You should be retired
and enjoying your golden years,
just playing golf
in your JNCO shorts.
Look at those shorts.
[ Laughter ]
I've never seen shorts that big
that didn't also have
a wallet chain.
[ Laughter ]
And then there's Roger Stone,
the Fourth Horseman
of the Weird-ocalypse.
Stone's been a long-time
confidant of Donald Trump.
And we told you yesterday,
the January 6th Committee
has also obtained
damning new footage
of Stone explaining
the Trump team's plan
to steal the election
to a documentary film crew.
For example, in one clip,
he just straight up says,
before the results are in,
that if the outcome
isn't clear right away,
the Trump team will just
claim victory anyway.
-Let's just hope
we're celebrating.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, I know.
-I suspect it'll be --
I really do suspect
it will still be up in the air.
When that happens, the key thing
to do is to claim victory.
Possession is 9/10s of the law.
"No, we won. [Bleep] you.
Sorry. Over.
We won. You're wrong.
[Bleep] you."
-He thinks he's
a criminal mastermind,
but he talks like
your father-in-law
over a game of Pictionary.
"No. [Bleep] you.
We won. I drew --
No. [Bleep] you.
I drew a way better pickle than
you, and Sarah said, 'Pickle.'
Tell them, Sarah."
"Actually,
I said, 'Microphone.'"
"Oh, my God, Sarah.
You're on your mother's side
now, Sarah?
[Bleep] you too."
[ Laughter ]
It's both dangerous
and also incredibly pathetic.
I mean, seriously,
can you imagine
these four in a room together?
"We won. [Bleep] you."
"My phone is blank."
"Oof! I sat on my balls."
"Thank you for being here.
Thank you for being here."
[ Cheers and applause ]
That -- You guys, that was very
exciting, what you just saw.
[ Laughter ]
That was rehearsal
for my new one-man show,
"Waiting for Go-D'oh."
[ Laughter ]
Ginni Thomas
is just the latest example,
but she is by no means
the only one.
Trump's gang,
and virtually the entirety of
the Republican Party,
have, like, bought into a series
of increasingly deranged
conspiracy theories,
and they were so devoted
to those insane theories
that they actually took
the very real steps
to overturn the election --
steps they laid out
in highly specific detail
in text messages and e-mails,
or on camera
over and over and over again.
There are so many
different stories.
The committee has to interview
so many different people
so they can go through...
-Different accounts
back and forth.
[ Laughter ]
-This has been --
Well, yeah, look.
Just remember how good
the one-man show was.
This has been A Closer Look.
♪♪
The midterm elections
are coming up,
so to make sure that you're
good to vote in this election,
visit our good friends
at HeadCount.org
to check your voter registration
status or to register to vote.